[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana como no podía ser
de otra forma tenemos un programa
especial de navidad eso sí sin alejarnos
de la actualidad navidades marcadas por
la cob y para ello me acompañan en este
estudio tres periodistas a las que ya
pasó a presentar gabriela bravo
corresponsal de radio cooperativa
bienvenida a gabriel aunque tan macho
ingrid rulo gamboa periodista
independiente bienvenida en grid muchas
gracias y paola ariza periodista
independiente bienvenida para las
navidades con comida hoy en primera
plana
bueno pues sin duda son unas fechas
especiales y quizá este año por el
contexto de crisis sanitaria lo sean aún
más nunca olvidaremos de estas navidades
con restricciones en muchos países con
la esperanza de las vacunas en el
horizonte pero marcadas por el miedo a
no contagiar a personas queridas
vulnerables una realidad que nos atrapa
a toda la sociedad en estas fechas
muchos países europeos y americanos
celebrarán las fiestas con restricciones
de movimientos toques de queda o como
poco llamados constantes de las
autoridades a la responsabilidad para no
tener por consecuencia un gran número de
rebrotes al inicio de 2021 vamos a
repasar algunas portadas que nos deja
este asunto diario the times en
reinounido dice que el primer ministro
johnson se niega a echar atrás las pocas
libertades con las que los británicos
celebrarán sus fiestas a pesar de la
amenaza a una tercera ola de contagios
el journal de montreal en canadá
navidades sacrificadas un sentimiento
quizá compartido por muchos en varios
países y aquí en francia le parisian con
otra consecuencia de estas fechas el
gasto
con todos los paquetes encargados por
internet de ello también hablaremos hoy
en el programa gabriela navidades con
kobe quizá la pregunta sea cómo
compaginar los afectos con la
responsabilidad en estas fechas creo que
es la pregunta que todos nos hacemos y
en un mundo ideal cartesiano donde las
recomendaciones que se dan fueran
aplicadas de manera estricta creo que se
podría hacer sin embargo los seres
humanos no somos así estamos hechos de
la parte salud pero también la salud
mental y hay que decir que durante todo
este año las personas han sufrido
bastante ya sea por estar encerradas por
no poder trabajar por por ejemplo todo
todo lo que es el mundo de la cultura
que se ha venido abajo entonces
lo que el gobierno ha tratado de hacer
es decirle a la gente responsabilizarse
es un sí sí sí sus familias se enferman
en esta navidad un poco ustedes tienen
una una culpa ahí y yo creo que no no no
no puede ser eso porque no somos seres
que estemos solamente dedicado a cuidar
la salud física la salud emocional es
muy importante y yo creo sinceramente
que los franceses van a aprovechar esta
instancia para poder volver a
reencontrarse en familia en sociedad y
dar rienda suelta un poco a estos
afectos que han estado tan contenidos
ingrid no tener los ciudadanos
conscientes de que estas navidades son
inéditas y son muy restringidas hay una
responsabilidad que se puede palpar o la
responsabilidad es que también yo creo
que la gente que tiene influencia tiene
que hablar más fuerte más duro para
decir responsabilicemos todos juntos
para que justamente porque si no nos
vamos a morir todos la gente de la
cultura por ejemplo está está peleando
está gritando y diciendo aquí en francia
tenemos que abrir los teatros etcétera
pero para mí yo no y muchos los los
cantantes los actores es decir nos vamos
a morir si ustedes no se responsabilizan
realmente porque claro el gobierno cerró
los teatros y todo pero para para qué
hay una responsabilidad también que la
gente de la cultura tiene que decir
cerramos los teatros nos vamos a morir
pero si el virus se para ahora si
podemos volver a abrir
y lo cierto es que la mayoría de países
europeos no solo francia también alemán
e italia han ido corrigiendo sus planes
que tenían previstos para navidad y los
han ido endureciendo por miedo a la
tercera ola es el caso que hemos visto
con alemania con suecia españa italia lo
vemos alrededor incluso en américa
latina'
y creo que ellos estaban en principio
los gobiernos pensaban vamos a salvar la
navidad
y ahora es vamos a salvarnos de una
tercera ola porque los casos han
incrementado tanto que el temor ya no es
no vamos a poder festejar juntos sino
que es el temor a vamos a tener una
tercera ola antes de la vacuna y
finalmente vamos a saturar hospitales y
los resultados pueden ser catastróficos
por cierto aquí en francia nos habla de
otra cosa el positivo que ha dado y
manuel macrón que tendrá que dirigir al
país hasta navidades recluído le
sorprende la cantidad de consecuencias
que tiene que el presidente de francia
sea positivo a esto no le ha caído bien
a emanuel macrón porque recordemos que
el presidente de la asamblea richard
ferrón dijo que
que si de alguna manera uno estaba
enfermo era un poco que se había
descuidado que no había seguido las
normas y hemos visto que en la prensa se
ha hablado de estas esta salida de norma
que tuvo el presidente macrón en una
cena donde se reunieron con personas que
no usaban la máscara que fueron 12
personas en un mismo lugar entonces este
positivo de manuel macro al al reverse
de otros presidentes que han podido
capitalizar esta enfermedad diciendo a
nosotros
miren nos somos como ustedes también nos
enfermamos le ha sentado mal al
presidente porque la gente lo critica
por la incoherencia entre el discurso
político que él da de decirle a las
familias francesas tienen que ser seis
personas en la mesa para esta navidad
ustedes tienen que cuidarse tienen que
cuidar a sus a sus ancianos a los
abuelos y por otro lado
saber que el presidente se ha
contaminado además dejando una ola de de
personajes internacionales que han caído
como el presidente español el primer
ministro portugués el presidente del
consejo europeo entonces es esta
enfermedad hoy para el presidente macro
no le ha caído bien al pueblo francés y
muchos dirigentes europeos lo hemos
escuchado esta semana al español pedro
sánchez o la canciller angela merkel
están hablando de intentar evitar en
navidades como objetivo la tercera ola
para entroncar con los procesos de
vacunación claro esto depende
completamente de cuánto nos
responsabilicemos en navidades ese
proceso de evitar la tercera ola y
comenzaría de seguido sus procesos de
vacunación
ingrid silala la vacunación ya está
llegando y todos tememos que la gente se
vacune o no yo no sé qué piensan sobre
eso pero todavía estamos tratando de
hacer una campaña lanzada a nivel
europeo para que todos los países a la
vez no a finales de diciembre sí para
que todo el mundo
pueda vacunar y contener justamente todo
todo el virus pero para mí tenemos que
ser siempre prudentes y ver y todo el
mundo tiene que ir al mismo tiempo o
pensarlo muy bien y paula así es es muy
importante ser prudentes en las
navidades creo que la gente encontrará
una forma de celebrar tal vez con grupos
más pequeños pero la invitación siempre
es a ser más prudentes sin embargo no es
sólo en las navidades si en enero
reabren bares reabren teatros cines
etcétera tendremos otros momentos otras
situaciones en las que nos podríamos
contagiar entonces sí hay que ser
prudentes en las navidades pero la
prudencia hay que tenerla siempre por lo
menos hasta que las vacunas no estén y
que todos no nos enfrentamos un poco más
seguros a la hora de salir o
encontrarnos con nuestra familia
nuestros amigos
por un lado están las restricciones los
toques de queda las libertades de
movimiento por otro están también muchos
países las recomendaciones que nos han
hecho es decir en el ámbito privado no
se sienten más de seis comensales a la
mesa no se junten más de dos hogares
diferentes
y contar con los niños 6 más los niños
10 comensales máximo que les parece en
toda esta batería de recomendaciones que
están diciendo de quienes se deben
sentar a la mesa navidad me parece que
las recomendaciones son estos
recomendaciones
creo que una recomendación la puede dar
un médico tal vez pero acá estamos
hablando de políticos tienen que dar más
bien directivas directivas políticas que
sean claras por ejemplo que haya que
introducir esas directivas políticas
niños por hacer abogado el diálogo viene
en la esfera del ámbito privado es muy
complejo pero por ejemplo que es que se
está respetando hoy en día de mejor
manera en francia el toque de queda
porque porque es clarísimo a las 8 de la
noche toda la gente en casa hasta las 6
de la mañana
y ahí se puede salir pero hay que tener
una justificación pero esto de
recomendar ustedes pueden ser 6 deberían
ser 6 lo mejor es que sean 6 es poco
claro y la gente dice bueno uno más uno
menos si le agrego dos que entre 6 y 7
entre 7 y 8 entre 8 y 10 y 12 bueno no
es no es claro aquí lo que hace falta es
claridad y tener límites y por supuesto
que la gente se haga responsable un poco
quería volver a esto de la vacunación
que yo creo que la batalla de la
vacunación en francia no ha sido ganada
hay que decir que francia 50% de las
personas no se quieren vacunar o y hasta
un 60 por ciento muestran una y una
desconfianza a la vacuna entonces esto
de la vacuna no es una batalla que ya se
haya ganado acá en francia lo cual
sorprende un poco esa cantidad de anti
vacunas que hay en ciertos países no
viendo que las vacunas es uno de los
grandes éxitos que ha tenido siempre la
humanidad nos y si llegamos a tan viejos
ahora es gracias a las vacunas
la ciencia es un poco sorprendente en
pesos como francia hablamos antes de
esas restricciones de esas
recomendaciones recomendaciones que
también se extienden a otras partes de
la navidad' como por ejemplo las
ceremonias religiosas nos aconsejan si
pueden ser alternativas telemáticas pero
yo no sé si es lo mismo ver para las
personas creyentes ver una misa por
televisión
a mí me causó mucha curiosidad una una
directiva que hubo que fue alrededor de
parís en los suburbios que de no
reunirse no es para la misa de navidad
por ejemplo pero en el caso de la ciudad
de nueva peaje por ejemplo el cura del
hogar para qué quería ser sumisa y le
pidió al alcalde de poder tener un lugar
grande con mucho espacio para poder
conservar las distancias y el alcalde le
dijo que sí y le prestó el gimnasio del
equipo de de val de basquetbol que es de
nivel nacional que tiene 3000 puestos
sentados y le prestó y le dijo aquí
pueden recibir hasta 750 fieles para la
misa de navidad en el gimnasio y van a
transformar completamente el gimnasio en
iglesia para que se puedan reunir en dos
misas a las 5 y a las 7 de la tarde y
eso pues causa mucha curiosidad
y pues es una solución cierto que la
prefectura no dio todavía la el aviso su
consejo pero como dice nada entonces
siguen preparando la misa si ya ve como
se está organizando aquí la gente de
cara a navidad vamos a irnos unos
instantes a una pausa pero a la vuelta
les quiero preguntar ya menos por
política y más a nivel humano como ven
esto de celebrar las navidades con la
copa de champaña al lado del gel
hidroalcohólico y la mascarilla a la
vuelta
ah
[Música]
y
la agencia de medicamentos y alimentos
autorizó el uso de emergencia de la
vacuna de moderna en eeuu esto da luz
verde para que miles de personas más
puedan comenzar a ser inmunizadas la
próxima semana hoy el vice presidente
mike pence se vacunó públicamente para
aumentar la confianza en las dosis
contra el hobbit 19 y mientras se
acercan las celebraciones de fin de año
varias ciudades de américa latina'
refuerzan sus medidas para frenar el
avance de la pandemia ciudad de méxico y
el estado de mexico cerrarán todas las
actividades no esenciales desde este
sábado y hasta el 10 de enero tenemos
reporte desde la capital
y en europa varios países también
adoptan medidas para hacer frente al
rebrote mientras acerca la navidad
francia superó este viernes los 60.000
muertos mientras el presidente manuel
macro cumple su segundo día de
aislamiento tras dar positivo por el cob
y 19
hola buenas noches en américa latina y a
todos ustedes que nos siguen en france24
hoy que es viernes sean bienvenidos
empezamos en eeuu la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos autorizó el uso
de la vacuna de modernas días después de
dar luz verde a la the fighter iv' hay
un tec tener una segunda fórmula
acelerará la vacunación masiva en el
país en medio del recrudecimiento de la
pandemia y para disminuir la
desconfianza de las personas a la hora
de ponerse las fórmulas el
vicepresidente saliente mike pence se
vacunó en público
graus holiday estribor récords de switch
también creo que la historia registrará
que esta semana fue el comienzo del fin
de la pandemia de coronavirus pero con
el aumento de los casos en todo el país
con el aumento de las hospitalizaciones
en todo el país tenemos camino por
recorrer y quiero asegurarle al pueblo
estadounidense que continuaremos
asegurándonos de que nuestros
proveedores de atención médica cuenten
con todo el apoyo y los recursos que
necesitan para enfrentar este momento
pero la vigilancia y la vacuna es
nuestro camino y afianzar la confianza
en la vacuna es lo que nos trae aquí
esta mañana en binghampton entender
quiénes fueron sus hijos de simón en
américa latina mientras se acercan las
celebraciones de fin de año varios
países refuerzan sus medidas contra la
pandemia y se preparan para vacunar las
poblaciones perú oficializó la ley que
declara como necesidad pública la
adquisición y distribución gratuita de
la vacuna contra el cob y 19 mientras
que uruguay cerrará sus fronteras desde
el 21 de diciembre hasta el 10 de enero
y en mexico la capital y el estado de
méxico las dos entidades más pobladas
del país endurecieron las restricciones
y cerraran
todas las actividades no esenciales
desde este sábado hasta el 10 de enero
para frenar el avance de la pandemia que
atraviesa su pico máximo en la capital
desde allí nuestro corresponsal mario
carbonero reportó cómo repercute en
estos anuncios en la sociedad
precisamente en la temporada navideña
buenas tardes pues la situación es
delicada desde el pasado 14 de diciembre
se superó el récord que se había
establecido en mayo en cuanto a la
hospitalización en la ciudad al alcanzar
cuatro mil 598 hospitalizaciones y desde
entonces a la fecha no ha bajado el
promedio actualmente pues estamos en
cuatro mil 800 personas hospitalizadas
de las cuales una cuarta parte está en
terapia intensiva el gobierno capitalino
ha estado enviando mensajes de sms a la
población para alertar de la condición
crítica en la que se encuentran los
hospitales varios de ellos están a su
máxima capacidad y hoy se realizó un
simulacro de la vacuna elementos
militares fueron al aeropuerto a recoger
las dosis en este caso de la vacuna de
influenza pues la de kobe aún no llega
al país y la trasladaron a un batallón
al sur de la ciudad para también ensayar
el tiempo de inmunización que es de tres
minutos pero en efecto la situación en
la ciudad y en el estado de mexico es
complicada
varios países se endurecen las medidas
en europa que vive el pleno pico de la
pandemia previa a navidad francia superó
este viernes los 60 mil muertos mientras
el presidente de manuel macro no cumple
su segundo día de aislamiento tras haber
resultado contagiado españa anunció que
comenzará la vacunación el 27 de
diciembre mientras que suecia por
primera vez ordenó el uso de mascarillas
vamos al informe de juán pupiales
francia es desde este viernes uno de los
siete países del mundo en donde la
pandemia se ha cobrado más de 60 mil
vidas con un registro total de 610
fallecidos en las últimas 24 horas la
nación vive por estos días bajo un toque
de queda con su presidente contagiado
imán de macrón cumple su segundo día de
aislamiento se encuentra en un hogar de
retiro cerca del palacio de versalles
dice estar bien y sus palabras son para
no bajar la guardia al instante es ruth
tenemos que cuidarnos los unos a los
otros durante esta época de festividades
eso es hago un llamado a cada uno de
ustedes cuento con ustedes hagamos lo
mejor que podamos nadie está a salvo de
este virus nadie así que resistiremos
todos unidos la vacuna llegará
seguiremos organizándonos para ella y
nos organice
en españa la comunidad de madrid' la
segunda región más golpeada por el virus
se dio y rebajó de 10 a 6 el número de
personas que pueden estar reunidas en
las fechas de navidad y además a nivel
nacional ya hay fecha para la vacunación
recibiremos las dosis de la vacuna de
variante kaiser el sábado 26 y el primer
día hábil acordado con los socios
europeos el domingo 7 de diciembre
españa empezará a administrar estas
vacunas
mientras tanto suecia un país que desde
el comienzo de la pandemia optó por una
estrategia basada en la voluntad de las
personas ordenó desde el 24 de diciembre
y por un mes el cierre de las
actividades públicas no esenciales
declarando obligatorio el porte de
mascarillas en horas pico del transporte
público alemania un territorio
considerado al comienzo de la pandemia
como un ejemplo a seguir
vive un pico que este viernes deja 813
muertos registrados desde el gobierno
reconocen que los meses de enero y
febrero serán los peores
reino unido y la unión europea siguen
sin alcanzar un acuerdo post break sit
debido a tres puntos de discrepancia el
uso de las aguas británicas para la
pesca la gobernanza y la futura relación
entre londres y bruselas el jefe
negociador de la unión europea michel
barnier advirtió que sólo quedan algunas
horas útiles para alcanzar un acuerdo y
evitar un break si duro uno de los
asuntos más críticos es la pesca si no
se firmó un acuerdo de aquí al 31 de
diciembre en londres amenaza con
prohibir el acceso a las aguas
británicas algo que preocupa a los
pescadores franceses en otros temas una
hipergigante está en curso de colisión
contra una isla británica para atender
la situación será enviado un equipo de
científicos en una misión urgente el
temor de las autoridades es que la jce
ver se atasque en el lecho marino y
causó un devastador impacto en la vida
silvestre local veamos
este es el expert más grande del mundo
nombrado a 68 a se desprendió de una
plataforma de hielo antártica en 2017 y
desde entonces se ha estado desplazando
lentamente hacia el desastre es el
objetivo desafortunado la isla
georgia el sur un territorio británico
de ultramar en el sur del océano
atlántico el a jesper es casi del mismo
tamaño que la propia isla y hoy se
encuentra a una distancia sorprendente
el daño podría ser catastrófico para las
plantas y animales locales
este haysbert tiene una quilla una
profundidad debajo de él que es de unos
200 metros entonces que podría hacer eso
a medida que avanza hacia la plataforma
de georgia del sur podría comenzar a
arrastrar el lecho marino y todas esas
asombrosas comunidades de organismos
bentónicos van a empezar a ser
destrozados
pero también tener un obstáculo físico
como este en las aguas alrededor de
georgia al sur podría presentar muchos
problemas más para los pingüinos y las
focas hwan
intenten salir de sus áreas de
alimentación no hay nada que pueda
detenerlo pero un equipo de científicos
británicos está preparando una misión
para estudiar los daños si el ice bear
se atasca podría pasar hasta 10 años
enraizado en el lecho marino por ahora
todo lo que los científicos pueden hacer
es revisar el metraje y esperar lo mejor
en méxico el exgobernador de jalisco
aristóteles sandoval fue asesinado en el
baño de un restaurante del centro
turístico puerto vallarta el estado de
jalisco en el centro occidente del país
es uno de los más violentos por la
acción de los grupos narcotraficantes
como el cártel jalisco nueva generación
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador lamentó el asesinato y prometió
investigar para que se castigue a los
responsables
seguimos en este país donde armando
manzanero continúa hospitalizado tras
ser diagnosticado con kobe 19 los
síntomas del cantante y compositor
mexicano de 85 años requirieron que ser
internada hoy en un hospital al sur de
la capital
manzanero o ganador de un grammy ha
escrito más de 400 canciones muchas
interpretadas por luís miguel como las
reconocidas somos novios y contigo
aprendí
cambio la página y finalizamos con el
nuevo estadio que presentó catar camino
al mundial de fútbol 2022 y es que el
comité organizador y la fifa presentaron
el ahmet bin ali frente a un auditorio
que fue sometido a la prueba de kobe 19
a 2 años para el partido final de la
próxima copa del mundo el nuevo estadio
albergará una capacidad de 40.000
personas y 3 y será sede de siete
partidos hasta la fase de octavos de
final los dejamos con estas imágenes
siga con más en francés 24
[Música]
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana hablando de un tema fundamental
navidades en tiempos de kobe y lo
hacemos con las periodistas gabriela
bravo y rulo gamboa y paola ariza bueno
psicológicamente para ahora a uno le
cuesta pensar que es en estas fechas un
abrazo a un ser querido puede ser el
peor de los regalos que nos queda
psicológicamente para asumir los afectos
en las comidas y cenas de navidad creo
que este año entero ha sido una
invitación a revisar la psicología de
cada uno todos nos tuvimos que cocinar
son muchas restricciones y ahora nos
dicen también restricciones para fin de
año que es un poco en lo que piensan
todas las familias
pienso que es muy difícil que la gente
se restrinja así lo recomendamos incluso
mucha gente dice es que deben utilizar
mascarillas cuando están con la familia
creo que es inevitable un abrazo o una
sonrisa con alguien con alguno de sus
familiares lo importante sería tal vez
reducir la cantidad de gente que está al
lado pero veo muy difícil que los
abrazos se supriman en este momento es
muy importante para la gente ahora
sentirse cercana a sentir que que tienen
a sus seres queridos al lado que se
acabó un año que para muchísima gente
fue difícil tanto a nivel económico
psicológico bueno tantos factores que
todos ya conocemos pero pongámonos el
día de la comida o cena de navidad con
gente en la mesa como evitamos no hablar
del monotema como evitamos de no hablar
del cob y en la comida o en la cena de
navidad porque parece inevitable ingrid
saquemos el juego de dominó alternativas
sí porque si no nos va a tocar yo creo
que siempre vamos a volver a hablar de
eso fue unas emociones que atravesamos
todos no juntos separados justamente y
eso fue fue durísimo pudimos al final
del año aquí en francia pudimos hacer
los niños pueden hacer deporte y no
pudieron ir al teatro no pudieron tocar
en el conservatorio instrumentos y todo
no ese tema es inevitable a mí me parece
que es inevitable nos nos va a tocar
buscar otra cosa o tomar mucha champaña
para tal vez por ejemplo no hablar de
las vacunas en la cena de navidad
y además yo no sé si claro todo el mundo
dice es que ya hay un hartazgo de hablar
del mismo tema hay un hartazgo pero
claro hay un hartazgo tocas otro tema
pero acabas volviendo al color es que es
imposible es que es imposible porque el
coronavirus ha tocado todos los aspectos
de la gira de todo todo absolutamente
todo desde que vamos a comprar es decir
todo ha estado normado por el
coronavirus incluso queriendo salir
queriendo tocar temas personales íntimos
todo ha sido tocado por este tema
entonces es inevitable que se invite a
la cena de navidad a la cena de año
nuevo es inevitable porque sí porque
digamos que la vida ha cambiado hay que
decir que la vida como la
seamos ya no es la misma vida es decir
esto ahora mostrar el afecto dar un
abrazo que era un signo de gran afecto
nos puede jugar en contra lo que era
positiva se ha vuelto negativo lo que lo
que era estar encerrado vivir a través
de las redes se ha vuelto positivo o sea
hemos se ha dado vuelta a todo un
paradigma de lo que era nuestra sociedad
y entonces es inevitable que todas estas
conversaciones salgan a la luz y se
inviten a la cena de navidad y estas
conversaciones pueden crear polémica en
la cena de navidad
lo que será la política o el fútbol
ahora es la cob y la política si
simplemente imagina la pregunta bueno y
si la vacuna llega la tomaría si tú
crees que si es también un poco la forma
de la de la gente saber es que yo
también me planteo la forma de hacerlo
si no es la vacuna
y las libertades que te vas a ir de
vacaciones inmediatamente ahora en todo
siempre habrán polémicas no faltan los
seres los familiares que tiene una
opinión muy fuerte y se ha dado arma
polémica entre ellos creo que es
inevitable inevitable tratar el tema de
corona de coronavirus yo propongo darnos
regalos para el momento en el que en el
que todos podremos un poco relajarnos y
la hora de la cena claramente propuestas
vamos a hablar de otras propuestas hay
familias que optan por navidades
diferidas es decir no celebrar las ahora
que es cuando toca sino pues pues en el
mes de julio en el mes de agosto han
hecho pactos incluso para reunirse más
tarde cuando todo esto haya pasado otros
dicen que claro hacer esto no es lo
mismo no es el mismo espíritu navideño
que les inspira esta idea de diferir las
navidades
porque no
que sería en un mundo ideal en un mundo
ideal donde el quabit se acabe pero ya
vimos que por ejemplo en la luego de la
primera ola que el presidente dijo
vienen los tiempos mejores los bonus y
finalmente nos toca una segunda ola y
estamos viendo que podríamos caer en una
tercera ola entonces yo creo que la
gente quiere celebrar ahora que se puede
que la app ha cambiado o sea en un
primer momento a lo mejor tras la
primera ola podríamos haber dicho está
bien vamos a diferir lo pero ahora la
gente dice es ahora o nunca porque si
bien y nos re confinan en enero o en
febrero y después no sabemos si de nuevo
nos van a reconfirmar en mayo si las
vacunas no son efectivas o no nos dan la
efectividad que esperamos la gente no
sabe si vamos a poder celebrar
finalmente navidad en agosto algunas de
las recomendaciones que nos comentamos
antes que nos han hecho a la hora de
sentarse a la mesa según país por país
máximo de comensales de núcleos
familiares habitaciones agregadas uso de
la mascarilla
acertamos limitando comensales haciendo
estas recomendaciones paula
probablemente sí pero como decíamos
ahora siguen siendo recomendaciones creo
que es muy difícil controlar a la
sociedad como tal también podemos
recomendar sea máximo 6 personas en la
mesa pero a veces falta la tía falta el
primo y esas reglas que se llaman
recomendaciones pero que en realidad se
tratan de volver más reglas creo que no
no son tan tan fáciles de seguir para
todos sería un ideal pero íngrid creen
que la gente en los entornos íntimos
respetarán estas recomendaciones es
decir ir con la mascarilla todo el rato
justo cuando te sientas ya te la puedes
quitar eso en un entorno íntimo parece
mucho más complicado de cumplir no y
sobre todo gente que no se han visto
durante mucho tiempo que tienen ganas de
abrazarse y yo creo que al principio por
tal vez a las 8 la gente va hacen de las
mascarillas pero yo creo que ya las
mascarillas también
si pis para comer para brindarnos las
mascarillas no van a y sinceramente que
no es que no es posible es como decimos
es el ideal en un mundo ideal cartesiano
en donde todo está hecho todo en una
hoja excel si funciona pero en la vida
real no qué le vamos a decir a una
abuela ya su nieto no la toques no no te
acerques a tu abuela no es imposible van
a salir al patio y se van a abrazar a
escondidas entonces yo creo que
es terrible esta enfermedad porque ha
hecho que nos replanteamos cosas que nos
parecían muy positivas muy buenas y
tener que alejarnos de los afectos
táctiles es muy difícil sobre todo para
nosotros el público latino y
mediterráneo comparten sí yo creo que
después de la primera ola que habíamos
inventado otras relaciones el vicio y
todo eso y podríamos hablar con los
abuelos con él pero ya nos cansamos de
los de las pantallas entonces es verdad
que ya no se pueden hacer más esfuerzo
yo creo que estamos al final de los
esfuerzos máximos que hicimos tenemos
que reinventar otra cosa otra vez no nos
lleva hasta el inss en el esencial yo
creo que la tecnología nos ayudó mucho y
pensamos que la tecnología iba a suplir
esta está este contacto humano ver a la
persona nos iba a ser suficiente y ya
ahora a final de año nos hemos dado
cuenta que no que nos falta nos falta el
lado humano
nos falta el calor humano y que por
mucha tecnología y avanzada que sea es
decir se pueden todas las reuniones se
pueden hacer ahora en videoconferencia
el presidente puede puede gobernar desde
el fol que gonzo por el teletrabajo sin
embargo nos falta nos falta esta
comunión este año que va terminando
estará sin duda marcado por la parte mía
pero aprovechando los minutos finales
del programa me gustaría que cada uno de
ustedes rescatar a una noticia un
personaje de 2020 más allá de la
pandemia para intentar el difícil
ejercicio den impregnarnos del todo con
magos dicho vamos a hacerlo justo lo que
hemos dicho vamos a intentar abrir otras
vías abrir otras ventanas a lo que ha
sido este 2020 que acaba que personaje
en qué noticia que les inspira este 2020
más allá de la cob y gabriela yo
elegiría un personaje más que un
personaje es un personaje colectivo sí y
son para mí los trabajadores esenciales
que digamos que en la punta de life air
los trabajadores de la salud los médicos
enfermeras y todos los trabajadores de
los hospitales y de la salud en general
pero también nos permitió este año ver
una categoría de personas que son
esenciales para el desarrollo de nuestra
sociedad a nivel mundial que por ejemplo
son los cajeros las cajeras de los
supermercados las personas que hacen el
aseo en las calles los agricultores y
que durante mucho tiempo han sido
invisibilizados menospreciados y que hay
que decirlo son personas que viven con
un salario o precario que tienen una
vida bastante modesta y nos dimos cuenta
en este año que son indispensables para
que nuestra vida pueda continuar en el
fondo un personaje un poquito
relacionado con lakovic todavía más
nosotros otras noticias otros personajes
paola creo que lo que más me marco de
este año han sido sin duda todas las
noticias de catástrofes medioambientales
entre esos los huracanes
el huracán eta que golpeó tan fuerte
centroamérica y luego yo está que fue
aún más devastador
por primero por primera vez a lugares
donde nunca se ha conocido tal impacto
como fue el del caso de colombia nunca
había llegado un huracán de categoría 5
a islas colombianas a destruir la
infraestructura total eso nos lleva a
replantearnos que el mundo
definitivamente está cambiando
medioambientalmente y lo estamos viendo
cada vez más
y para terminar ingrid a ti con qué te
quedas de 2020 hace un poco distinto
quizá si tal vez les parezca más fútil
pero para mí
que mi tema es la cultura y sobre todo
el baile es que el breakdance llegó como
disciplina oficial en los olímpicos va a
llegar en los olímpicos de 2024 y para
mí es una una pues una reconocencia 6 un
reconocimiento muy muy importante porque
durante muchos años la cultura urbana y
las disciplinas urbanas fueron muy
deprisa das muy maltratadas por los
medios y ahora es ese reconocimiento me
parece muy importante porque para el
breakdance es a la frontera entre el
arte y el deporte que eso es una
polémica también pero para mí es pues
algún deseo para 2021 aparte de que se
vaya proto desde 2003
bueno que no empecemos con una tercera
ola de contagios yo creo que es lo más
lo más prudente que podemos seguir al
año 1000 que la que las vacunas sean
efectivas y que ésta podamos dejar
realmente este año bastante terrible
detrás de nosotros pues así terminamos
muchísimas gracias a las tres y a todos
ustedes que pasen lo mejor posible estas
navidades muchas gracias
[Música]